ascorbic acid in water has to be  formulated at a lower pH so that it can  get into your skin hi I'm a cosmetic  chemist with the PHD in Medicinal  Chemistry and it's a bit more  complicated than this this study that  made people think you need below pH 3.5  for vitamin C to work and that is  actually what the researchers say but  this is an oversimplification in the  study they use a very simple water-based  vitamin C solution there's not much  going on in there the only thing that  helps the vitamin C get through is the  low PH it makes the vitamin C a bit more  soluble in skin but with more complex  formulas they can use things like  penetration enhancers they don't just  have pH and so you can't really rely on  this test